quand on a grandi en bretagne on est
forcément un jour attiré par la mer
anthony a 19 ans et veut devenir marin
pêcheur il va essayer d'obtenir un bep
de pêche vincent à 20 ans il veut être
sauveteur en mer
il devra réussir l'examen du bnssa
cécile penker les boycottons ont tout
juste 17 ans ils veulent devenir matelot
dans la marine nationale
ils ont décidé d'apprendre un métier qui
leur plaît et ont tous choisi chacun
dans leur domaine
l'école de la mer
celle qui vous apprend tout de suite si
vous êtes fait pour ça
valeo ainsi se passe
[Musique]
quand
cécile n'aime pas les bancs de l'école
elle est déscolarisé depuis la 5ème
toutes les portes se ferment sauf une
celle de la marine nationale
elle s'inscrit à l'école des mousses de
brest
j'y vais
dans la base navale cécile est déjà sur
l'eau travaux pratiques sur petites
embarcations sait s'il veut devenir
manouvrier et diriger un jour la
conduite d'un avis
on se sent pas
donc jamais atteint dans deux semaines
on passe aux perroquets
on se doit comme ça après avoir été on
pourra faire plaisir
la marque côté vador
là j'ai raté je me disais que j'allais
faire qu'est ce que je vais faire de ben
ali et par rapport au niveau scolaire je
me suis maintenant il faut des bacs et
je me sentais incapable je me sens
toujours incapable d'avoir un bac se
cache pas je n'aurai jamais mon bac je
me suis dit je vais essayer école des
mousses à une fois ce que l'arc est un
peu bas je me suis peut-être que je vais
réussir ça m'apporte une grande chance
la chance de pouvoir avoir un métier
directement la femme l'a dit et je suis
pas un vrai que pour le métier je suis
montré aussi pour la discipline
on a ici c'est personnellement ça m'a
changé beaucoup de caractère on a besoin
de cette histoire je pensais pas plus
mal de gars que j'ai changé
[Musique]
anthony et fils d'agriculteur pas
question pour lui de rester planté au
chant il n'y connaît rien au métier de
marin-pêcheur les décident de tout
tenter
il vit au bord de la mer à paimpol et
s'inscrit au lycée maritime au
simulateur de navigation
anthony goûtent aux plaisirs du large
mais virtuellement une façon comme une
autre de prendre la clé des champs
ouais un petit peu de chances que ce qui
bouge j'avais envie de voir
oui tu pars et je me bats au tpr on est
tout seul rêve on est tranquille sur
luca personnes nous casser les pieds je
me posais troqué jeu quelque part que
j'ai pour le risque continue à rester
chez mes parents vous travaillez à la
nicotine
[Musique]
mouais pas être blessé à rien je peux
être le bateau cas derrière ça vient
chez toi
ouais projeté sur un bateau de pêche
pour aller pêcher bah ouais j'avais
vraiment été mal géré j'ai pas mal vous
me le moindre effort dit fait envie de
vomir t dégoûté presse a un début et
binche à l'alcool metois pris un jet à
prix direct j'ai appris bas quand on
navigue la nuit à reconnaître des
bateaux j'aime rien réparer des filets
j'ai appris à faire des nues j'ai je
dois réussir pratiquement bah ouais
c'est bien ça serait mieux si ça sera un
vrai bon on commence là dessus on finit
fort un point break je pense
gc
là j'en écoute
et
paul cottin à tout juste 16 ans il a
choisi l'école des mousses parce que la
vie militaire c'est ce qu'il veut
marcher droit et trouvait une raison
d'être qu'il n'a pas ailleurs
pour être sincère
est ce que vous êtes en sécurité alors
voilà strateco tu as une aide en jambes
et non serre sous tension elle est beau
c'est le côté marche au pas et tous
ensemble être unis être tous pareils
tous égaux comme ça ça évite tous tout
ce qui est raciste pour tout ça c'est
des choses que j'aime pas du tout donc
au moins là on est tous égaux
on a tous la même tenue on fait tous
exactement les mêmes choses superbes
cottin veut devenir le mécanicien d'art
à l'école des mousses 1 apprend avant
tout à être un marin accompli dans tous
les domaines sous la houlette du premier
maître pierre il a cours de manoeuvres
d'accostage d'un bateau et il est obligé
d'en passer par le home était en mémoire
ce qu'on a appris autrement on restera
là jusqu'à midi jean rien moi
cela si jeune homme à part un ou deux
les hôtes et une bulle à temps on n'est
pas là pour s'amuser voulait pas faire
manoeuvrier d'accord mais c'est la base
de la marine c'est soit clair maintenant
là c'est tellement simple qu'on fait
attention à sa marque
cottin aimerait prendre le large dans la
base navale on est entouré de grands
dossiers
une invitation au voyage
télémédecine été déçus c'est ouvert jack
l'ancien régime
des pages
oui
ouais j'en vois bien qu'on assume bien
les émissions et des voyages et je
voulais voir en fait c'était vraiment ce
qu'est ce qu'ils disaient voyage mais
j'ai déjà été en egypte et j'adorais et
je vous retournez dans des pays comme ça
mais
[Musique]
vincent était étudiant il cherche un
petit boulot pour cet été il se dit
qu'ils pourraient être majeurs
sauveteurs dans un poste de secours sur
une plage il devra passer l'examen du
bnssa
le brevet national de sécurité et de
sauvetage en mer
les paysans
il suit une année de formation à la snsm
de brest alors tous les week-ends il
s'entraîne à sauver dans l'espoir à 20
ans de faire quelque chose de grand
matic wafo ça s'est un peu inconnu en
fait je pense que je sais pas trop quoi
attendre je pense que je serais assez
fier de moi c'est un peu bête à dire
mais voilà c'est même si les gens à 8
vienne pas nous dire merci c'est génial
de savoir que ben voila et cette
personne là il va pouvoir rentrer chez
elle cnsf bas je pensais suffisant
le sauveteur est jamais tout seul c'est
vraiment si on travaille pas en équipe
ça peut pas marcher
on est toujours super on sait qu'il y
aura forcément du bon pour nous épauler
si on a eu un problème et tout ça sera
jamais tout seul
ok le poste n'est pas loin d'une fête
une aide à la marche
le mettre à l'abri et au chaud à la fois
dans la cour qu'est ce qu'il faut faire
on l'a décemment ces amours là on a tout
coupé
tu penses que et maintenant ça apporte
quelque chose oui sur certains noms
l'entr'aide qui est très présente et ben
je pense qu on fait plus attention aux
autres peut-être après mais plus
vigilants ce que les gens ressentent et
comment ils sont dans la vie quelques
semaines on passait nos apprentis vont
bientôt entrer dans le vif du sujet ils
vont enfin savoir s'ils sont vraiment
faits pour ça demain embarquement en mer
prévus pour tout le monde alors il
serait bon de bien se reposer cette nuit
à l'école des mousses on a compris qu'il
fallait apporter du concret aux jeunes
impatients
cécile et cote 1 vont prendre la mer
pendant trois jours et être affectées au
métier qu'ils ont choisi
ils vont découvrir la vie à bord de la
frégate tourville
alors
bienvenue à bord
au quai dans le port colonnes déboîtée
la frégate tourville un bâtiment de
combat de lutte anti sous marine avec
ses tourelles sont mm ces missiles
elle-même 38
autant dire un beau joujou pour copains
les arts tirs
oui
de dire
j'aime bien
cécile elle doit rejoindre l'équipe de
manoeuvrier sur la passerelle
c'est tout au bout de la longue course
yves central du tour vie
c'est par où passait manon gît sous la
table et six blessés tu vois c'est bon
tu sors là tu vois à l'avant
cécile va essayer de bach et l'immense
frégate 250 m 2 à la barre et nice à
gauche vers 1930
bah ouais ok c'est pas très facile de
tout simplement jaloux cet alcool la
grèce et sur différents bateaux c'est
pas aux jeux mais cinq mois à la 1ère ça
en 1937 ça m'évite de me vider la tête
tous les problèmes je laisse ici et puis
quand je parle au mr bah je pars avec un
nouveau cerveau
voici le 2 juillet vous avez votre
affectation vous êtes embarqué sur tel
ou tel bateau vous avez votre équipage
félicitations pour c'est à dire mon père
seulement je trouve ça va le construire
je me dis ben voilà c'est quelque chose
d'acquis c'est quelque chose de gagner
et puis c'est une nouvelle vie voilà je
déploierai neveu lui
être marin dans la marine nationale
c'est si les copains doivent mesurer
qu'il s'embarque aussi pour une vie de
militaire et thierry durteste le
capitaine de vaisseau est réputé pour
avoir un certain charisme quand il part
en mer avec ses hommes c'est pour leur
faire subir une série d'entraînements au
combat à la passerelle avec ses adjoints
il prépare un mac opex pour demain
autant dire que personne ne sait à quoi
s'en tenir
[Musique]
il est 5 heures du matin bang
un indice il aurait touché le tour 10
bravo
durant un mac opex la totalité de
l'équipage est rappelé aux postes de
combat avec plus ou moins de succès
vous vous habillez vous rallier la zone
avant 8
mais bon
on se lance
m'énerve ça
ah les copains tu voulais faire
mécanicien d'armes c'est le moment
d'essayer
[Musique]
7 on passe à une menace de vedettes
rapides eux
comment dire à interdire pour cela
d'abord eux
ouais bon
renault
c'est bien
alors comment le respect des coûts
ça ne sais pas comment expliquer depuis
les belles années qu'on était là on fait
on voyait des reportages mais n'allez
pas trop voir nos métiers en fait je
vais choisir le métier avant de voir
comment c'était vraiment et lâche
vraiment sûr du métier que je veux faire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tapant c'est un petit peu la nation
combattu musique les militaires pour
cent y pense elles pointent pour
l'instant pour l'instant je n'y pense
pas trop je sais pas trop comment ça
peut se passer
j'ai pas trop encore de jeu c'est pas
exactement comment ça peut se passer les
gradés nous en parle pas trop donc je
sais vraiment pas après ses 11 ans
engagé dans l'armée aussi pour défendre
notre pays donc s'il ya besoin sera
obligé d'être présent
la vie peut réserver des surprises et
vincent lui aussi va vivre son métier en
gras dans lance du fort de bertheaume
les vedettes de la snsm prépare la
grande journée du scénario catastrophe
et stéphane est le maître du jeu
[Musique]
il y aurait le jeu
j'emploie volontairement le conditionnel
il y aurait un certain nombre de
naufrages et dont je n'ai pas pour
l'instant connaissance un certain nombre
de naufrages et à l'eau vous allez avoir
à faire des investigations à la palme et
d investigation sérieuse dans les
cailloux dans les failles
derrière chaque tas de vous aimons on
est bien clair les consignes sont bien
comprises
ok équipage à vos sodiac qui apparaît à
parier sur ordre
les anciens sont là pour entourer et
former les jeunes stagiaires ils sont
tous venus en bénévoles et donnent de
leur temps pour transmettre la passion
du sauvetage
la particulière
donner du temps pour faire comprendre à
vincent les responsabilités qu'il va
accepter d'endosser à seulement 20 ans
face aux vives
c'est vrai qu'il faut être professionnel
du sauvetage en mer c'est vraiment lui
bénévolat c'est pour ça que vous êtes
passionné je consens fumer faire ça si
quelqu'un vient là juste pour travailler
et filmé sur la plage ça marche pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
oualalou
[Musique]
anthony l'autre fils d'agriculteur va
lui aussi prendre la mer
le patron du tome léo l'a appelé en
renfort pour une journée une journée de
stage pour se former pour de vrai le
rendez vous est fixé à 2 heures du matin
las vegas un coût important revers à
être critique
si je peux faire anthony va vivre une
longue sortie en pêche il ne reviendra
qu'à 17 heures eric le patron est allé
poser plusieurs filets au large il y a
quelques jours les petits coefficients
de marée permettent de les laisser en
place et d'aller les relevés en espérant
une bonne pêche eric à ces coins secrets
référent
mais pas là
anthony va pouvoir faire un petit peu de
cartes tout à l'heure les patrons plus
jeunes maintenant montrent plus
facilement ils laissent plus facilement
faire un coeur ça il vaut mieux faire un
cas chacun d'une heure que faire quatre
heures et puis est un petit peu
somnolent à la barque
retour éclair valérie
il fait une symphonie faire un peu le
cas 1
il n'y a pas de quoi lire rade
y'a pas de barbe est oui
elle
blatter présent sans faire attention
c'est aux boîtes au carré partout pour
faire attention mais on veut voir les
vélums
boehner qu'on apprend l'école à faire
[Musique]
non
arrivé à destination tout est clair
léger recours
il y à sept filets a relevé anthony
devra trouver le rythme pour des mailles
et les crabes et les poissons sans
ralentir les autres
anthony fait du mieux qu'il peut il
travaille en silence tête baissée sans
nous dire un mot pendant plus de six
heures d'affilée
avec son bep anthony pourrait travailler
sur des chalutiers de 12 mètres et faire
de la pêche côtière
s'il est embauché à l'année il peut
espérer gagner jusqu'à 2500 euros par
mois ce qui n'est pas rien à 19 ans
d'abord des soupes une pause et
tranquille
était dangereux alors oui peut-être un
peu tôt
la télé est dit souvent et qui a des
bateaux qui coule mais moi ça me fait
pas peur jeudi un bateau qui coule c'est
sûr mais en appelant à côté aussi qui
reste il faut beaucoup de multiples
forums des poissons marins pêcheurs et
fier de l'être
anthony est fait pour ça
moussa a bien
rentré au viol ça bouge pas il fait
chaud
et c'est joli en face j'adore quand on
rentre ça
ces moments que j'aime bien si les
sénégalais c'est égal voyage et du
poisson tout ça
système u 15 mois est un petit peu trop
long
un peu tranquille
c'est déjà la fin de l'année il reste
peu de temps pour réviser dans le
dortoir des filles cécile demande de
l'aide à ses copines les évaluations
écrite pour le brevet élémentaire de
mousse vont commencer des chinois faites
moi je parle de répondre je vous le dis
que je réussis à la page restera pas
impuni au final avant je vous disais
ouais bon âge qu'on tende rime à rien
j'ai essayé j'ai essayé final je veux
manger comme des bulles donc alors là
déjà
bonjour à tous ce qu'il ya à prendre je
vous narre facilement ce qui me paie que
j'ai envie de baisser les bras toujours
tout ça personnel maintenant si je vais
marcher une bulle je n'arrive à faire
le plus petit
cissé s'il échoue elle ne pourra pas
refaire une année elle aura toujours la
possibilité de rejoindre un lycée
professionnel
mais le voudrait-elle vraiment
[Musique]
on y est
la réussite de l'examen est un métier au
bout pour vincent une journée d'épreuves
en piscine pour les autres 4h décrit
dans chaque matière
[Applaudissements]
c'est vraiment le mental qu'il faut
réussir à dominer et faut pas paniquer
même si c'est passé d'entraînement au
jour d'examen faut pas se rater
j'ai compris du tout autant sera pas
présentée est ce que j'aurai 0 au lycée
maritime de paimpol
anthony semble plus confiant sa semaine
d'examens s'est plutôt bien passé assez
bon jouer or voilà aussi voilà le bep de
pêche en poche et pour vincent c'est la
sphère de quelques secondes annonce les
amis morgon
dans le sac orange du sauveteur vincent
découvre son affectation emploi il va à
talmont-saint-hilaire sur la côte
vendéenne une plage touristique face à
l'océan et ses longs rouleaux fait que 5
hommes dangereuse qu'il y aura un peu de
un peu d'activité sûrement après je
connais pas pas trop drôle la commune
est coin mais je pense que ça va être ça
va être sympa je me pose pas de
questions
[Musique]
à l'école des mousses de brest c'est la
cérémonie officielle de remise de
diplômes
l'atelier soit fier de ce projet bien
mérité leur succès avant de plancher sur
2012 fait du bien je respire à pleins
d'autres étapes comme celle ci cécile
c'était sous-estimer
[Musique]
changeant j'ai pris de la maturité enfin
je trouve tellement j'étais un peu tu
peux acheter j'étais complètement
démunis
oui ça donne confiance en moi
les voilà tous les deux avec un beau
contrat de quatre ans dans la marine
nationale
côté 1 partira à toulouse sur un aviso
et cécile restera à brest sur un
chasseur de mines
anthony a décidé d'apprendre plus ses
émotions à rome
il va retourner au lycée pour tenter le
bac pro il pourra partir plus au large
et travailler sur de plus gros bateaux
et notre sauveteurs en mer vincent il
est là quelque part dans la foule
[Musique]
c'est moins intense qu'un entraînement
pas de grandes sauvetage ni de
sensations fortes mais pour vincent et
les autres un premier succès se sentir
grandir et cela fait du bien droit à
lyon
[Musique]